today on the Matt Walsh show the media
claims that many Americans still don't
want to leave their homes and get back
to the lives they want to stay
barricaded in their homes there they're
not ready to be done with the lockdown
yet if that's true fine and that's why I
propose that everybody who wants to get
back to work and back to their lives can
do so and if you want to stay home you
can I think that's the path forward it's
an easy solution what's the problem
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the arrest of the
two men who shot a mod our Bri and we'll
talk more about that case today
especially in the email it's got a lot
of email about it and in our daily
cancellation I canceled a news channel
that shamed a guy for the crime of
operating his ice-cream truck and you
have to see this video just to see how
proud of itself these quote-unquote
journalists are for shaming this guy so
we'll talk about all that coming up but
first as mentioned a new poll done by
ABC says that 65% of Americans don't
want the economy to reopen now I have
trouble believing these polls because
they don't at all reflect what I hear
when I talk to people and I often think
even though it's unscientific I think I
do think sometimes your own anecdotal
experience of just the vibe you get from
people when you talk to them I have
found that to be more reliable than
these media polls much of the time in
many circumstances but let's say let's
say for a minute okay whether these
things are accurate these are accurate
polls well fine we still know - despite
what with some but supposedly 65% of
Americans want we know that there's no
good reason for the lockdown to continue
there wasn't a good reason for the
lockdown to begin in the first place but
almost everything we have learned in the
last two months has made that truth
inescapably clear okay so to be in favor
of the lockdown two months ago is one
thing to be in favor of it now is quite
another because we have a lot of data
under our belt now a lot of experience
and it all points to the fact that this
that there is no justification for this
over 33 million people have been put out
of work many businesses on the brink of
or over
edge of bankruptcy our economy teeters
near total collapse and all of this not
to prevent deaths or to stop the virus
but merely to delay the inevitable
moment when we have to figure out how to
live in spite of it
this is all a delaying tactic there are
still people I think a lot of people in
this poll don't understand I think part
of the reason why they're in favor of
the lockdown is they still don't and
probably because they're getting their
news from places like CNN they don't
understand what the lockdown is actually
supposed to accomplish it's not supposed
to save any lives really it's just
supposed to delay it's a delaying tactic
for most of us the risk of returning to
our jobs and our lives is very low the
virus primarily victimizes the old and
the infer my has had a hugely
disproportionate impact on nursing homes
as I argued a few days ago I laid out
the numbers we talked about this in many
states and many countries nursing home
fatalities account for more than half I
mean sometimes we're talking 70 80 90 %
of all kovat 19 fatalities when you add
the elderly who are not in nursing homes
okay so that's just specifically people
in nursing homes then what about the 75
and overcrowd who are not in nursing
homes and then you also add in people
with pre-existing conditions it becomes
evident that young and healthy people
are very unlikely to die from this
disease or to be hospitalized because of
it in fact young and healthy people I
mean the the the the threat of death
from Cova 19 for a young and healthy
person isn't that much more than the
threat from the flu that's just that's
what the numbers tell us I know we're
not supposed to make these comparisons I
don't care that's what the numbers tell
us now that doesn't mean that we should
cavalierly throw aside all precautions
and safety measures and just throw it
all to the wind and everything no that's
not what it means and that's another
problem with these polls is that I think
the way it is presented is do we have a
lock down or do we do nothing whatsoever
and just pretend like everything is
normal like those are the two options
that are presented but that's not
actually the people who want to end the
lockdown most of them that is
not what they what we are proposing you
could still have plenty of safety
measures plenty of social distancing
measures you can take plenty of
reasonable precautions while sort of
going about your lap your life the and
if you do that the threat level as a
healthy person to you will be quite low
and we should be and this is the point
we should be allowed to take that risk
if we wish for people who for a culture
that supposedly values autonomy and
being pro-choice so much
I think this position should be
appreciated we should be able to choose
to take that risk of a wish but this
brings up an important point the
argument the retort is that well even if
the young and healthy go back to their
jobs if we allow that to happen and we
allow them to reclaim their lives well
the problem is that there they might
spread it to people who are not in that
category
so remember Governor Cuomo said a few
weeks ago that for all the people who
want to for the people have the audacity
to want to get back to their jobs and
feed their family he said it's not about
you it's not about you it's not about
you it's about me I mean it's basically
exactly what he said and that's that's
that's the argument that's that's the
retort is well what about all the people
so you want to take the risk but because
you could become a carrier are you not
now forcing other people to take a risk
and also what about even healthy people
who don't want to take the risk what
about them is is it fair that all these
people should have the risk wasted on
them against their will and that's where
I say no it is not fair but that's not
what we're talking about here there is
another way and I'll explain that in
just a second but before we do a word
from our good friends at zipper Court
recruiter you know a lot of people are
of course unfortunately looking for a
job right now and we want to make their
job search as
efficient and effective as possible
because II don't have a lot of time to
waste
zip recruiters focus hasn't changed
they're still doing what they've done
from the beginning helping people who
need jobs find work at helping growing
businesses find the right people for
their open roles
so what zipper crews always done and
that job is more important now than it
has ever been literally so if you're
looking for a job right now know that
zip recruiter is working with you to
find the right job faster zip recruiter
is dedicated to helping you get hired
whether you're looking for jobs and
caretaking to delivering food and goods
to building medical facilities to
supplying protective equipment so much
more there are many jobs that need to be
done even now in fact zip recruiters app
will send you up-to-date job openings so
you could be the first one to apply and
if you're actively hiring zip recruiter
will invite candidates to apply to your
most urgent roles making it faster and
easier to reach the people you need by
connecting people who need jobs and
companies that need people zip recruiter
is working with all of us so that we
could keep moving forward let's work
together
zip recruiter comm slash work together
ok so is it fair we some of us want to
go back to our lives but are we not
putting other people in harm's way
is that fair well it wouldn't be fair
wouldn't be fair to put people on people
in harm's way against their will which
is why I would be against forcing anyone
to leave their homes and the really good
thing is that nobody to my knowledge has
advocated such a policy so I am NOT the
only anti lockdown person who would be
against forcing people to leave lockdown
I I think every way I'm not aware of any
anti lockdown person who wants to force
this on anyone that's not what this is
about in fact this is the anti force
it's the other side that's all about
forcing people to do this and that we're
saying no this is this is not about
force now the way it is portrayed by the
Pro lockdown crowd you would think that
those who oppose the lockdown want to
mandate that everybody leave their home
but we are in favor of no such mandate
and have not proposed one this to me
seems rather simple if you want to
remain in your home that's
fine stay there as long as you like you
need not worry about anyone spreading it
to you if you're still hiding behind
locked doors I don't even understand the
concern if you want to stay it locked
out and you're saying you can't leave
your home because you're gonna spread it
to me how am I gonna spread it to you
you're in your home I'm not I'm not
breaking in so you're fine what's the
issue you should be just as safe after
the lockdown ends as you were before it
ended because you're still personally
staying in your home no problem but if
you don't want to stay in your home then
you can leave only those who choose to
take the risk should take it and there's
no reason why I should be prevented from
taking the risk just because you don't
want to take a risk you and I are
different people we live in different
homes we don't have to make the same
decision that's the great thing about
being autonomous beings whatever
happened to that let me make my choices
and you make yours
now a common counter-argument to this
plan so a counter-argument to my
counter-argument to their counter
arguments where a lot of counters now
but they'll say well if many people get
back to work and business is open again
then some of the people who want to stay
locked down might be compelled by their
employers to come back to their jobs so
maybe there are people who are working
from home right now but if we start
opening up again maybe the employer says
you got to come to work we're gonna fire
you or you know maybe maybe there did
their job has allowed them to maybe
they're furloughed or whatever the case
is the concern is if we open up the
economy and I don't want to leave my
home whereas before my employer was
accommodating it they might not
accommodate it anymore
and then I'm out of a job now this
strikes me as an ironic and hypocritical
concern considering the source
after all if you're if you're pro locked
out if you're in favor of continuing
lockdown then you believe that 33
million lost jobs is a price worth
paying you're afraid you're gonna lose
your job if the lock downs end well the
lock downs themselves resulted in 33
million people losing their jobs you
were okay with that in fact you've
probably scolded the people worried
about losing their jobs for quote
putting money over human life so now
what you're doing the same now that you
stand to lose your own job suddenly job
loss is a problem 33 million unemployed
people isn't enough to justify hoping in
the economy but one lost job yours is
enough to justify keeping it closed I
mean do you see why this line of
reasoning is not particularly endearing
or persuasive people who have
pre-existing conditions that put them at
high risk of Cova 19 should be
accommodated I think and provided
provided for so that they can remain
home I don't think that we should be you
know I think if someone is in a
high-risk category either because of
their health or their age they should
remain home and they should be
accommodated which is a lot easier to do
than accommodating everybody I mean the
government sending stimulus checks to
everybody or at least everybody under a
certain income bracket that's not
sustainable
sending stimulus checks to a much
smaller group of people a targeted
smaller group of people who have to stay
home because of their health condition
that I think is much more sustainable
and that's something we could do the
elderly you know most of them aren't
working anyway so they should remain
quarantined but the young and healthy
ought to be given the option to return
to work if any young and healthy person
wants to stay home indefinitely because
they're afraid they're free to make that
choice I don't think we should subsidize
that choice that's that's yes that's
correct if you're young and healthy
you're not sick you're not elderly I
don't think you should be forced out of
your home
but I do think the lockdowns should end
and I don't think we should subsidize
you I don't think you should get any
checks from the government you know if
you want if you want to stay home
indefinitely because you're afraid of
germs and viruses you're free to do that
but you got to figure out how to make
that work for yourself I don't think
that it's society's job to make that
work for you we're gonna get the economy
going we're gonna we're gonna get
society rolling again if you don't want
to be a part of that fine but we're not
gonna pay you you know we're not gonna
pay you to do nothing but again these
are the people who like to preach about
the superfluous 'no son's doing a time
like this these are the very people
who've been saying how dare you be
concerned about finances all right well
now I'm saying to you how dare you be
concerned about it you didn't care about
the finances of 33 million people who
lost their jobs am I supposed to care
about yours I mean you'll forgive me if
I treat your financial situation as
superfluous considering you've done that
to everybody else in the country and now
it's a problem now if your financial
concerns are not superfluous then you
might decide that it's worth it to get
back out into the world and take the
risk and that's a decision you should
have a power to make we should all have
the power to make let everybody figure
out their own priorities their own needs
their own acceptable level of risk let
them choose which door they're going to
walk through and then walk through the
door that's what it means to live in a
free country let's move on to headlines
number one we talked yesterday we talked
yesterday at length about the case of
mod R burry who was shot dead in the
street by Gregory and Travis McMichael
the McMichaels father and son duo
claimed they were just making a
citizen's arrest but for reasons that I
went into detail explaining yesterday
that excuse just really doesn't wash at
all
now that McMichaels have been arrested a
day after the video when public arrests
were made but the shooting happened back
in February and Prosecco
have had this video in their possession
for a while now so why did it take
public outcry to spur arrests that alone
is an enormous outrage it would seem
that local law enforcement intended to
cover this up and let the killer's go
without facing any kind of trial and if
that video doesn't come out these guys
are still on the street that seems
obvious remember the first two
prosecutors in this case recused
themselves because of their connection
to the elder McMichael it's obvious that
the people the powers that be down there
making these decisions in Georgia really
didn't want to prosecute these guys
really didn't want to well and why is
that many people say it's because of
racism I think another potential
explanation is that the elder McMichael
is a former cop and to me this all reeks
of cops trying to cover for one it for
their own you know cops looking out for
their own kind of thing that's that's
that's what it seems to me to be and it
certainly wouldn't be the first time
that happens number two the unemployment
rate is fourteen point seven percent or
in fact numbers just came out today the
unemployment rate was fourteen point
seven percent in April which is
officially the highest unemployment rate
since the Great Depression and I think
the highest unemployment rate since they
started officially tracking these
numbers in the 40s when you factor in
the people who are underemployed and
that they went from full-time to
part-time that number is 23% remember
that's just April and remember this does
not count the millions of people who
haven't filed or couldn't file or or
don't qualify for unemployment so the
worst unemployment rate since the Great
Depression is actually an understatement
that's actually a very conservative way
of putting it and we did all this we
locked 33 million workers in their homes
because of a virus that mostly kills
people in nursing homes and then we kept
sending infected people into the nursing
homes amazing I really
historians of the future will spend
their whole careers trying to figure out
what happened here and why we did what
we did and they won't be able to
understand it and I don't understand it
either
three speaking of nursing-homes reading
now from The Daily wire it says
unbelievably despite the fact that
elderly people in senior care centers
have been the hardest hit demographic in
the corner virus crisis the state of
California where Governor Gavin Newsom
has instituted harsh lockdown measures
is asking assisted living facilities to
house elderly patients infected with the
corona virus in exchange for money so we
know in New York there was a mandate
passed back in March
forcing nursing homes to take infected
people and there was what we talked
about few days ago there was one nurse
come in particular had that had no
corona corona spyer's cases or deaths
they were forced to take in to
coronavirus cases and then shortly after
they had 30 people died and that is a
direct result of the mandate of the
policy in New York which means it's a
direct result of the actions of Governor
Cuomo he has that blood on his hands I
don't see any way around that and now
you've got similar things going on in
other parts of the country in California
they're gonna bribe you to take in
coronavirus pate Colonel as far as
patients it's incredible I mean to have
this level of uncounted competence and
it's still happening even now I also
don't want to here when I talked about
this few days ago some people the excuse
some people offered is what else are you
gonna do if you have an elderly person
who has coronavirus what el where else
you gonna put them they need
around-the-clock care where else you
need to put them here's my answer to
that literally anywhere else okay
anywhere else would be a better place
than a nursing home and besides what
about all these extra facilities that
were set up especially in New York they
set up all these extra facilities that I
mean
in ships and everything most that stuff
ended up going empty what about putting
the what about putting the elderly
colonel about coronavirus patients there
and giving them around two o'clock care
instead of setting them right back into
a nursing home and nursing homes which
by the way were not given time to set up
and be prepared to handle this and so
the virus spread like wildfire and yet
these governors who are doing this cuomo
knew some you know the governors who
have the worst outbreaks and have
handled it
most incompetently they're the ones
hailed by the media the media is
constantly falling to their knees
polishing andrew cuomo's
shoes talking about what a great job
he's doing how they should replace Biden
with him and yeah anybody would be
better than Biden for the Democrats
probably at this point but even Andrew
Cuomo but here's the way the media is
presented you want to talk about living
in an upside-down world the governors
who have the who've had the worst
outbreak and I've had the worst response
to the outbreak they're the ones who are
hailed as heroes while the governors who
have the the health who have best
controlled their outbreaks like in
Florida are somehow the villains of
coronavirus the way the media talks
about the governor of Florida who not
coincidentally is a Republican I mean
they're trying to make him out into the
into the great villain of this story
they don't have a serious outbreak in
Florida we've been told though over and
over again that there would be a serious
outbreak remember the Spring Breakers
everyone was freaking out about the
Spring Breakers oh my gosh the Spring
Breakers they're gonna kill us all what
ended up happening with that they went
home and they were fine what we were
told that five or six of them at
coronavirus what did they die no
apparently it was okay it really worked
out fine actually four and yeah and
Andrew Cuomo on top of sending
kronosaurus patients in nursing homes he
also decided to clean the subway system
for the first time this
week this thing's been going on for two
months and this is the first time that
he's shut down services overnight to
actually do a thorough cleaning of the
subway system yeah but what a brilliant
a brilliant leader brilliant leader
what great brilliance me gimme give me
one good can anyone hearing how
brilliant of a leader he is but why what
is he actually done that's good point to
the success he sounds great in press
conferences
yeah his press conferences are great
great press conferences really comes off
great honey and he has those cute little
interviews with his brother on CNN are
they so cute together
yeah that's what matters which even that
can you imagine if Fox News had a
employed a member of the Trump family
imagine of Don jr. had his own show on
Fox News and he did every night did
interviews with his dad where he was
just telling his dad how great he is do
you think the left and the media do you
think they would be gushing about how
cute and wonderful and lovely these
moments are between father and son the
way they do with the brother brother
thing on CNN no they would say this is
outrageously inappropriate this is bad
journalism or in the middle of a
pandemic okay if you if you've got
someone on an elected official who's
who's heading up the response to this
weather in New York or nationwide you
need to actually ask him some good
questions don't don't bring in a family
member to question him for and here's an
odd way to pay tribute here's a tweet
from NY the NYPD it says JetBlue
aircrafts will conduct a flyover over
Manhattan
over Manhattan Queens and the Bronx to
salute frontline first responders and
health care workers the aircraft's will
fly at approximately 2,000 feet please
follow social distancing guidelines if
viewing in public
that's oh my gosh what what are we doing
first of all it's New York why would you
think that people are gonna be excited
to see commercial aircraft flying low to
the ground through the city like of all
the ways to pay tribute in New York how
is that your go-to and meanwhile the
NYPD's constantly are they're arresting
people for not social distancing and now
you're staging a spectacle for people to
come outside and see number five okay
there's too much anger I got to calm
down I need to find something positive
okay so here we go I you know I play a
lot of tic toc videos on this show for
good reason because that's always news
relevant news
usually it's tick tock videos that have
gone viral and usually them in a
negative way but I want to inject the
little positivity so here's a viral tick
tock video that I personally found both
informative and inspiring watch this
today I want to show you what this
American girl likes as hot tea so I mix
a lot of ingredients together so first
it's one cup of Institue two cups of
tank country time lemonade one cup of
sugar another cup of sugar a little bit
of cinnamon a little bit of cloves mix
it all together put some water in a cup
heat your water in the microwave add a
few teaspoons to your hot water give it
a little stir and that's what I like for
hot tea that looks delicious
I that's is a true culinary geniuses are
never appreciated in their own time so
people are making fun of this woman for
that recipe but she will be remembered
by history and revered and in fact this
snack kind of reminds me of a snack that
I came up with if you're looking for a
meal to eat with that delicious tea
here's one you could try this lightly
fry some bacon you wrap it around a
Snickers bar cover with shredded cheese
put in the microwave for five seconds
just enough to get the cheese a little
bit melty and then you top it with gravy
eat it with a fork and knife I'm telling
you you won't regret it you might regret
it but but it's good anyway especially
if you happen to be say on death row and
you're looking for a last meal you've
given up all hope of living then I would
recommend that one to you all right now
for your daily cancelation but before we
go to your daily cancellation I want to
take a moment to tell you about daily
wires newest most exclusive membership
to your that is the all-access insider
the all-access insider membership here
is our premier level of membership all
access members get the benefits of other
membership tiers including an ad free
website experience access to our live
broadcast full three hours of Ben
Shapiro show all access members also get
other amazing benefits including of
course the singular and irreplaceable
leftist ears tumblr they also get to
join live exclusive online Q&A S which
is daily wires new discussion show which
are which is which are you know a lot of
fun and they also get to participate in
all access live our brand new
interactive programming feature so you
get all that stuff and I think but
here's the main thing you're just a
better person okay our our all-access
insider members are more valuable as
people than anybody else and that's
that's the main you you get Worth and
dignity as a person from this so head on
over to daily wire comm so I've
subscribed to join daily wires
all-access Club with a new membership or
an upgrade and get 10% off with coupon
code Walsh that's daily wire comm size
subscribe see you there okay now if your
daily cancellation I am canceling
everybody who had anything to do with
this segment from CNN
[Music]
that iconic music screams summer and we
all scream for ice cream but during a
pandemic social distance the rule
getting close to the ice cream man could
mean getting something else fact of life
yet here's mr. freeze not his name in
his truck of treats unmasked unclogged
taking cash for cones in the northwest
burbs
that's when cbs2 assignment editor Greg
Kelly father of two dead on a bike said
wait a minute
dude it's a good idea to be doing this
with the stay-at-home order covered 19
eventually our Greg got a bit closer
tried to get an answer from mr. freeze
again not his name at this time face
coverings are required in public
situations where social distance cannot
be maintained
[Applause]
he drove off it for the questioning by
our assignment desk editor dad biker and
journalist Greg Kelly but this all
happened in Hoffman Estates and tonight
we'd learn ice cream trucks there our
band have been for years the village
manager tells us if you see that ice
cream man call 9-1-1 I just honestly if
you told me that segment was done as a
parody of the lockdown and of all the
paranoid neighborhood snitches if you
told me that was a parody a satire of
the coronavirus busybodies I believe you
I would believe that that was some kind
of Babylon B skit 100% I would believe
it it is hard to believe that that is
real but it is real and I'll tell you
what makes it hard to believe even
though it is again indeed definitely
real but see I can always understand I'm
never perplexed when a person does
something very stupid that never
confuses me I get it there are dumb
people out there who do dumb things but
when that very dumb thing has to go
through an approval process and a bunch
of other people have to be involved in
it and so now you've got this whole
chain of dumbness and throughout that
entire chain nobody apparently even once
spoke up and said wait a second guys I
think this might be very dumb that's
when it perplexes me and they're so
proud of themselves the tool bag on the
bike the reporter everyone they post
this on social media they're so proud
CBS they're so proud of it they they
thought this is now this is great work
guys it's not just that they didn't
think it was dumb they thought they had
a hit on their hands they thought they
had a Pulitzer Prize winner which who
knows maybe they actually will win a
Pulitzer Prize considering where they
give Poulter's to these days but they
thought they had something and they'd be
getting applause from everybody for this
that's what they thought here they are
harassing and shaming a man who's trying
to make a living here they are bullying
a working-class guy in an ice cream
truck and they feel totally vindicated
totally righteous like they're fighters
for truth and just
in the American Way it's amazing what
absolute idiots and that's the most
charitable thing I could possibly say
about them I have an idea here's a
better idea okay
mind your own damned business leave this
guy alone let him earn a living you earn
a living if you're in the media you
still have a job
god forbid this guy try to make some
money - what you're the only guy you're
the only person it's a lot to make some
money that that a-hole on the bike what
he's basically saying is excuse me sir
are you trying to earn money no no I
only I can earn money I can earn money
you can't how dare you sir try to earn
money like me by deeds earn money I'm
important but you're just an ice-cream
truck driver I mean even if it was
necessary to shame this guy which it
isn't at all not even a little bit at
all no it's not at all but even if it
was why would you think that you as a
person in the media someone who has a
job and is well compensated why would
you think that you of all people should
be the person to do it just really
disgusting meanwhile this guy is outside
he's sir me he's serving you know
children outside the virus doesn't
really spread outside kids don't really
contract it or spread it this is one of
the safest jobs in the world to do there
is no reason and if anyone's being put
at risk it would be him as the ice cream
truck driver if anybody's at a and you
know he's not really in any real risk
either but if anybody's at risk it's him
so he's making a decision because he
wants to earn a living and he wants to
any wants to sell some ice cream there
is no reason why ice cream truck
shouldn't operate during this in fact I
think we could all use some ice cream
right now I think we can use the sound
of an ice cream truck driving down the
street there should be more of them not
less we should be setting out fleets of
ice cream trucks how about how about
injecting a little bit of joy and
normalcy into all of this bleak mad you
know
madness especially
kids kids have been locked in their
homes they can't see their friends I got
four of them it's it's tough on the kids
and they don't they don't underst
understand why they can't leave that I
don't understand it either they
especially don't understand it so I
think it's great not only is it great
this guy's earning a living I think it's
great that he's you know something a
little bit normal and something fun for
kids so they can enjoy themselves
through all this we've taken everything
away from them we've taken their friends
from them we've taken away the
playgrounds
we've taken away birthday parties and
everything you know Easter took that
away from everybody not just the kids
that's just cancellation is should only
be the beginning of our response to that
okay let's move on to emails you can
always email the show if you become a
daily wire member you can email even if
you're not one of the elite insider plus
members you can still email the show but
I might not respond to the email because
frankly I only respond to the most elite
two people because I am an elitist
myself this is from Marshall says hi
Matt love the show question have you
seen planned emic what did you think
yeah planned emic is this video that's
going around I haven't seen it yet
I've been asked about it a million times
I've heard a lot about it as I I admit I
have not seen it so I can't say a lot
about it a couple things I will say
usually whenever I say I can't say much
about something that's a prelude to me
saying a lot about it so number one I
know that they've been taking this thing
down fry I guess they took it down from
YouTube took it out for Facebook Twitter
Vimeo I mean I think they've taken down
and I'm I'm absolutely against that I
don't think they should be removing the
video they should let people watch it
and form their own opinions but first of
all if if you're a skeptic about the
government's narrative with respect to
coronavirus
good you should be skeptical I'm
skeptical too but if you're a skeptic
then you shouldn't go and watch some
internet documentary and implicitly
trust everything it says because then
you're not a skeptic okay
then then you're you're just a sort of a
cultist too but you you're looking for a
different cult to join and so it always
makes me uncomfortable it's you know
there's the every time there's some big
news event there's always look at one of
these conspiracy videos making its way
online and there are people who become
devotees of this video and they say you
got to watch it it's like with 9/11 that
was always a sight guys that that thing
and yeah so I don't I haven't seen but
what I would say is you should
definitely watch it with very healthy
dose of skepticism and I can say that
without seeing it because you should
have skepticism about everything which
is just another way of saying being a
critical thinker and then and then
beyond that I would also say I don't
know how much this thing gets into the
conspiracy arena and seeing it just the
name of it planned emic makes it sound
like conspiracy it was planned right it
seems to be implied I think we should
remember that most of the time with the
government you don't need to get into
conspiracy theories to understand what
they're doing and why they did it
usually things like just really simple
but sort of more boring explanations are
available and are far more plausible
most of the time like moral cowardice
and competence selfishness political
posturing those sorts of things that
explains most of what the government
does you don't need to get into smoky
rooms plans being hatched if that's what
this thing does I don't know if it does
or not but you don't need for that and
because we can explain so most of what
has happened with the core virus
response it's you know I keep saying I
don't understand it while I'm being
facetious I do understand it I know why
they're doing it most of them for the
reasons I just gave it's cowardice
okay there are a lot of Governors who
jumped on this bandwagon because they
didn't want to be one of the ones to
stay open and you know and then they
were afraid that even even if it's the
right thing to do they were afraid that
the body count would be blamed on them
and they didn't want that so they were
just covering their own asses
a lot of incompetence they just don't
know what they're doing a lot of
selfishness they're only worried about
their own the you know themselves and
their own image a lot of political
posturing they're just trying to figure
out what's the what's the best political
move here not what's actually the best
thing to do what's the best political
move and so I think it's been a whole
lot of that and that unfortunately is
enough to explain why we plunged
ourselves into a great depression and
put 33 million people out of work to
address a virus that mainly kills people
who are 85 years old or over over okay
let's go to Thomas as Matt I think
you're too hard on some of our elected
officials when it comes to the
coronavirus response there was a lot we
didn't know early on they acted on the
best information we had some of that
information was bad blame China I think
that's where your anger should be no I I
disagree with you yeah I mean blame
China we should be angry at China but I
I think that in our anger at China we
should not lose sight of the fact that
our own government deserves quite a lot
of anger as well in fact the great
depression that we're now heading into
and 33 million people unemployed that is
not the fault of China actually that's
because China isn't the one who set our
policy yeah they may have sent the virus
here sent in this in the sense of it
emanated from from them and perhaps from
one of their laboratories so it may be
their fault that the virus came here but
they didn't set the policy they didn't
decide how to respond to it they
responded how they responded but they
didn't make that decision for us we made
that decision and would by we I mean
government people in government
bureaucrats and elected officials so
they should get a hell of a lot of our
anger and you say we didn't have all the
information early on well sure we didn't
but there was a lot of stuff we did know
early on the fact that it mainly affects
the elderly we knew that early on the
fact that it doesn't seem to be
affecting children that much we knew
that early on there's a lot of basic
stuff we did know early on and there
were
epidemiological experts and so on who
from the very beginning were saying this
is not the right approach it's just that
the powers that be decided to listen to
different quote-unquote experts and I
think they made that decision for all
the reasons I just outlined and also
even if we didn't know everything no you
don't shut down your economy and destroy
your society just in case let's just
shut it all down and figure it out as we
go along no that's not the right
response that's not what you do you
don't put 33 million people out of work
just in case right just as just as a
precautionary measure while we kind of
figure out what's happening I would
argue that that is not the right
response I would argue that if you don't
have all the information and you don't
know exactly what's going on that's all
the more reason not to do exactly what
they did okay this is from Paul finally
says your analysis of the Georgia
shooting was terrible in many ways you
always say you want citizens to step up
and not rely on the government well
that's what a citizen that's what a
citizen's arrest is all about they were
doing exactly what you say people should
do in handling a situation to protect
the neighborhood I think you're just
trying to appease the left by buying
into the racism narrative okay Paul and
I've heard this about piecing the left
many times in the last couple of days
and first of all do you really think
they were think I'm trying to appease
the left you think you think that's what
I'm worried about doing I mean did you
watch the show yesterday where I spent
the first 20 minutes basically insulting
feminists and and about the birth
control issue it's like if I'm trying to
appease the left do I do that
is that a segment I decide to do you
look at my whole body of work you think
appeasing the left is my goal because if
it is I am really bad at it I I if it is
I am the worst appeaser that has ever
walked the earth no consider the
possibility
that I'm not trying to appease anyone
I'm just telling you how I feel about it
consider the possibility that I'm a
human being with a brain and I'm trying
to evaluate a situation and come to my
own conclusion this idea that that every
time you happen to agree with the left
on a particular issue
you're appeasing them is so dumb and so
boring just stop it with that do you
really think do you think ever but what
are you how do you evaluate an issue
because it seems to me Paul that you and
a lot of other people what you do is a
situation occurs and you look at
whatever the left is saying and you just
say the opposite okay that's no better
than just fault that's the same thing as
following the crowd that's the same
thing as being a bandwagon jumper that
means you're not thinking for yourself
rather than judging every issue by
looking at what some other group is
saying and taking the opposite and
unthinkingly taking the opposite
position rather than doing that why not
use your head look at the evidence read
the police reports rewatch the video
listen to the 911 calls and come to your
own conclusion if you do that I do not
see how you could possibly really
believe based on what we know that this
was a legitimate citizen's arrest come
on in fact we know that it's not and I'm
not even basing this on anything other
than what the McMichaels themselves said
so based on their own version of events
this was not a legitimate citizen's
arrest because what do we know from them
what do we know we know two things
number one they did not see a crime
occur number two they thought he looked
like someone who had committed a crime
not that he did they saw a crime we know
that number two we also know that they
grabbed their guns and and went after
him and told him they just want to talk
that's not a citizen's arrest
brandishing a gun and they were
brandishing when you're holding a gun
that's brandishing a gun it's not like
they had the gun holstered I mean the
one guy was holding a shotgun so but but
he
so they were brandishing brandishing a
gun chasing after somebody brandishing a
gun and telling them you want to talk to
them that is not a citizen's arrest that
is not how a citizen's arrest works he's
not no you do not have the authority to
do that as a as just a random dude and
if you're a if you're another random
dude and and some random dudes roll up
on you with guns and say come here we
want to talk to you you don't have any
responsibility to listen them you have
every right and every reason in that
scenario to think they mean you harm
because you don't grab a gun and go up
to a guy in a hostile way unless you're
willing to use it and so if you're the
one being pursued you have every reason
every right to think that they mean you
harm and to respond accordingly which is
what this man did no they were not
defending themselves he was defending
himself against people came after him
with a gun not a citizen's arrest you've
got to drop that that's not what it was
in fact like I said listen to the 9:1
cause someone did a 9-1-1 call and I you
know I I saw this 911 call because
defenders of the McMichaels were for
spreading it around online as if it's
some kind of you know part of the
expression some kind of smoking gun
evidence in in favor of the McMichaels
so I listened to the 9-1-1 call and it
it makes them look even worse the 9-1-1
call was it wasn't one of the McMichaels
it was some other guy
call the police to report that there was
a guy in a on a construction site in a
half-built home that was a home that's
open and that that was the report and
then that one operator asks him is he
breaking in did he break in and the guy
on the call says no it's open and then
he's asked and then the 9:1 operator
asked what is he doing wrong we'll send
the cops tell me what he's doing wrong
the guy can't explain it the guy doesn't
give any reason of what he's doing wrong
just that he looks kind of weird these
on a construction site and then he
leaves and he runs off that's it so the
9-1-1 call is that a guy was on a
construction site in the middle of the
day and was in a half it
built home briefly and then left and you
think that's reason for three armed men
to chase him down are you kidding me
come on what do you think do you think
if I'm what if I'm in I'm in Walmart and
I see a guy looks like he might a
shoplifter but I'm not sure he looked he
looks sort of like a guy who would
shoplift you know would I be justified
if and let's say I'm carrying a gun you
know would I be justified him pulling my
gun out following him into the parking
lot and saying holding my gun saying
come here I want to talk to you and then
if he gets scared because he thinks I'm
trying to abduct him or kill him which
would be a reasonable conclusion and a
struggle ensues and I shoot him dead in
the parking lot but you think I did
nothing wrong
all good just bit just being a attentive
good citizen no I'm gonna go to jail for
that that is at best vigilantism well
that's that's the best spin you could
put on that okay you it's you don't have
to be very creative to see if if we
allow this kind of thing like armed
citizens to just grab guns and chase
down people who look like they may have
possibly committed crimes and question
them at gunpoint like do you really
think that's what we should allow that
that's that's what the law should be I
don't think you do think that Paul I
mean the people who are reflexively
defending the McMichaels on this I it's
one thing if you want to take a position
of we don't know all the facts let's you
know let's let's let the process play
out okay fine
but the people who are offering full
throated defenses like you are of these
two guys even after the video that you
saw III don't I just I just flat-out
don't believe that you really think
objectively they were justified i
flat-out don't believe it I don't
believe you what is your motivation I
don't know but I
believe it because this is any rational
person should at a minimum say there is
cause for concern here it's good they
were arrested we need to look into this
all right all right
in fact one other example okay I got to
finish up in fact if you think about it
we've all maybe a lot of us have been in
in a situation not unlike this didn't go
this way but what I mean is think about
a time when you have seen someone in
public acting in a suspicious way a lot
of us have been so example for me a
little while ago I was on the road there
was a car in front of me driving very
erratically okay clearly somebody on
drugs are drunk you know this is one of
those things very obvious from the way
the car was was was driving and so I
called the police because this is
someone who could kill himself or
someone else you know I'm not gonna just
let him drive off feel like I have a
moral responsibility so I called the
police and I followed the car at a safe
distance just so I could tell the cops
where he was going and pretty soon the
cops got there and I left my part was
done okay what I had been justified in
running the guy off the road and
grabbing a gun and telling him to come
out and talk to me or in fact forget
about the gun what if I had just run him
off the road and in the process he
veered off into a ditch hit a tree and
died would I be at least partially
responsible for that I am the one who
ran him off the road I think he would
say yeah I mean I killed the guy you
might say well he was in danger already
but I killed him and my actions directly
killed him and so I would go to jail for
that so the analogy here is clear they
they could have followed the guy today
he was on foot they were in cars it to
cars it was actually three guys in two
cars with guns for an unarmed dude in
the road in the middle of the daylight
they could have just followed him and
waited for the cops to show up it's they
weren't
in a desert six hours from the nearest
police station no instead they wanted to
be the hero they wanted to play tough
guy that wanted to play Action Hero
they were acting like they were in a
movie someone died they killed them they
need to go to jail I'm glad they were
arrested very glad for it okay we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
everybody have a great weekend Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there